die erde ist ständig in gefahr von einem
heftigen sonnensturm getroffen zu werden
und diese mission könnte dabei helfen
die menschheit davor zu schützen
die europäische raumsonde solar orbiter
ist anfang der woche richtung sonne
gestartet und im laufe der mission wird
sie sich dem gestirn auf bis zu 42
millionen kilometer nähern das ist der
absolute wahnsinn und diese sonde wird
zum ersten mal bilder von der sonne
machen die es vorher so noch nie gab
krieg zum science fiction gibt es
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocken nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
die sonne ist für forschungsteams
weltweit noch eine große unbekannte und
außerdem auch eine gefahr die
weitestgehend unverstanden ist zwar
nehmen teleskope und erdmann satelliten
ausbrüche der sonne war
doch dann muss auch eingeschätzt werden
wie stark der ausbruch ausfallen wird
und ob er die erde überhaupt treffen
wird erst 20 minuten bevor ein sturm die
erde erreicht wie es dann auch klar in
welche richtung sein magnetfeld zeigen
wird und das ist entscheidend dafür wie
gut er das irdische magnetfeld
durchdringen wird derzeit spielen wir
quasi russisches roulette mit der sonne
doch das könnte bald ein ende haben denn
die europäische raumsonde solar orbiter
hat sich in der nacht auf montag von
florida aus auf den weg in richtung
sonne gemacht bis auf 42 millionen
kilometer wird sie sich im laufe der
mission der sonne nähern und das
bedeutet dass sie eine wirklich krassen
strahlung ausgesetzt sein wird ein
hitzeschild soll die sonde und ihre
instrumente bis zu einer temperatur von
bis zu 8 500 grad celsius schützen
insgesamt zehn instrumente werden die
sonne durch kleine fenster ganz genau
ins visier nehmen mit ihnen sind nicht
nur ferne messungen möglich sondern auch
die analyse der direkten umgebung der
sonne und das wird allerhöchste zeit
denn es ist wirklich verrückt obwohl die
sonne wohl der meist beobachteten sterne
überhaupt nicht stellt er für fachleute
weltweit ein grosses rätsel dar
mit hilfe des solar beta soll endlich
geklärt werden wie sonnenwende entstehen
mit einer geschwindigkeit von bis zu 2,7
millionen kilometern pro stunde
katapultiert der stern einen strom
geladener teilchen ins all
hinzu kommt der mysteriöse kosmische
schluckauf urplötzlich werden milliarden
tonnen geladener teilchen im
sonnensystem
er hat bereits 15 stunden später reichen
die schnellsten dann bereits unsere erde
und das kann nicht nur für stromnetze
sondern auch für satelliten und gps zum
großen problem werden
im schlimmsten fall werden
milliardenwerte zerstört unter strom
fällt flächendeckend inklusive aller
kommunikation aus ein absolutes desaster
ein weiteres großes rätsel den mann mit
dem solar orbiter endlich auf die
schliche kommen will
die temperaturunterschiede zwischen der
sonnenoberfläche und der korona damit
ist quasi die äußerste schicht der sonne
gemeint der begriff corona ist
lateinisch und bedeutet soviel wie kranz
oder krone die krone bildet also wenn
man so will die atmosphäre der sonne den
sonnenbrand der mehrere millionen grad
heißer ist als die oberfläche der sonne
in der korona können bis zu 5,6
millionen grad celsius herrschen bei
5500 grad liegen die temperaturen auf
der sonnenoberfläche
doch warum ist das so rätsel über rätsel
dazu nicola fox eine wissenschaftlerin
des nasa sonden projekts der
entstehungsort des sonnenwindes die
atmosphäre der sonne ihre corona muss
extrem energiegeladen seien 300 mal so
heiß wie die oberfläche der sonne
das widerspricht den naturgesetzen es
sollte keine wärmequelle geben die
heißer wird wenn man sich von ihr weg
bewegt dort gibt es irgendeine
zusätzliche energie irgendeine schwarze
magie der solar- wind- löst sich nicht
einfach von der sonne er nimmt irgendwie
auch ihr magnetfeld mit sich egal in
welche richtung es zeigt wie stark es
ist es erstarrt im sonnenwind fachleute
weltweit spekulieren ob das magnetfeld
der sonne die erklärung dafür sein
könnte man geht davon aus dass in den
äußeren regionen der sonne gas aus
geladenen teilchen aufsteigt plasma das
sinkt dann wieder ab und wird außerdem
durch die rotation des sterns
durcheinandergewirbelt ein super
komplexer prozess also doch die chancen
dass solar orbiter neue erkenntnisse
dazu liefern kann es in groß das
max-planck-institut in götting hat ein
instrument entwickelt das die stärke und
richtung des magnetfeldes genauer
analysieren und vermessen soll ein
forschungsteam der uni kiel hat sensoren
entwickelt die den stoff messen aus dem
der sonnenwind besteht dazu wird sich
solar orbiter kurz zur sonne drehen und
wieder weg und es den messgeräten und
teleskopen so erlauben ihm gehen
den himmelskörper hineinzuschauen dazu
robert wimmer schweingruber aus rostock
unsere geräte haben wir natürlich auf
herz und nieren geprüft wir haben sie
geschüttelt und gerüttelt wir haben sie
erhitzt und gekühlt und wir haben alles
getan was wir konnten um sie zu plagen
mit hilfe von weiteren instrumenten soll
aber auch der ursprungsort des
sonnenwindes in der korona identifiziert
werden und zudem auch noch nach
röntgenstrahlung geforscht werden die
von europäischen auf der
sonnenoberfläche stammen könnten handelt
es sich dabei etwa um die heizung der
atmosphäre sechs bis zehn jahre lang
soll solar orbiter jetzt die gelegenheit
bekommen die sonne aus der nähe zu
beobachten
die geschichte zu der sonnensonde ist
allerdings schon eine ältere dazu der
göttinger astrophysiker sami solanki
ehrlich gesagt beschäftigt und solar
orbiter seit mehr als 20 jahren
max bank forscherinnen und forscher
hatten also schon in den 90er jahren die
idee für eine neuartige sonnensonde
gehabt entwickelt wurde solar orbiter
von der us-weltraumagentur nasa und der
europäischen raumfahrtagentur esa das
kontrollzentrum der sonde befindet sich
in darmstadt und die kosten der mission
werden auf 1,5 milliarden euro geschätzt
der plan sieht vor dass die von ihr
gesammelten daten die daten der parasol
abhob ergänzen denn die nasa-sonde
dieser 2018 enge bahnen um die sonne
zieht kann keine hochaufgelösten bilder
von mir aufnehmen solar orbiter
dagegen soll sogar von den polen des
sterns erstmals bilder machen und daten
sammeln
warum stirbt die sonne anklicken
anschauen und astro comics tv abonnieren
cooler kanal klar ob bis dann bleibt
dran